quante coppe e va verso sparito subito
un attimo fa mi introdurre gigante di
lava esseri spregevoli tu madre teresa
preparati il tuo primo combattimento
quindi fa attenzione io volevo
introdurre il video però che la dea mi
protegga asti gran cazzi dalla dea posso
dire beh la tutina ogni anno da pro si
calma è che vi stare calmo e parola
marco ma fatto ok
clicca suonava tar dell'eroe proseguire
la sua suprema
ok lo fa è la madonna è suprema anche
lei forte forte
facciamo qualche a castro mostro in
genere né in tutti i giochi non devo
leggere scusate se nuova via ciotti
umani il potere il coraggio è già nelle
mani della regina
speriamo che ci abbia le bocche pure lei
accidenti siamo caduti nella trappola fa
chi è perfetto e latenti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono
faringei pedaggi siamo sul league of
angels che sono riuscita introdurlo per
miracolo divino non so come sia
impossibile economica è partito subito
chiesto gran figo siamo sul rigo
vengeance è il secondo video di giornata
tra l'altro quindi alle armi di un
sereno ok buca banane no vabbè ma
facciamo una tipa con eccola adecco le
qualità di un personaggio sono queste le
qualità che un personaggio deve avere
cos'è sta roba goes estero non si
capisce proprio perché questo gioco mi
affini vero alla o contro caps vedo che
anche gli altri scelgono nomi molto
sobri allora ragazzi io sono pupa banane
evocatori di eroi e che estrae per
ottenere il loro dell'eroe completo
va bene con un evocazione normale puoi
ottenere eroi rario epici va bene ma che
culo è mi esce subito l'epico veramente
riuscita subito eredi ps va bene tanto
eppure [ __ ] karen è un eroe in grado di
infliggere molti nannini
vabbè ce li ho quindi adesso posso
usarla è giusto prima di affrontare una
battaglia schiena un eroe ok ma devo
schierare gli eroi battaglia va bene e
sono tre due figlie della madonna mister
pupa banane si appresta ad andare a
combattere boating pre volevo salutare
gli altri
vabbè motivi mikaela ciao tesoro non
vedo tanti york in serie a quando la
regina dei flagelli fu sigillata pensa
che io non vedo così tante tette insieme
dal ma mai poppa banane temo che a
reginali flagelli se va bene a far
finire io angelo mi batterò ebbe anvedi
che angelo figurati se non ti batti per
una così ma che comunque volevo dirvi
ragazzi che sono orchi si perfetto
volevo dirvi la cache in partenza in
genere i giochi così sono tipo ti fanno
combattere contro vostri piccolissimi no
per per farti capire come si gioca in
questo è partito che c'è stato un
colosso di 4 metri caso scrive contiene
presi mietere che ti forniscono grandi
bonus tributi ok quindi posso dare fa
temere usare no
sotto banale anche micaela non è male
tanto che sono a livello 3 già come
possibile alloggiare anche così facile
ok dragonero sì perché volevo scrivere
in chat
potevi scrivere in già fermi dovrebbero
salutare tutti salve gente
ecco adesso sicuramente qualcuno mi
risponderà contento chi l'avrebbe detto
agostino e guardiano della reliquia ok
devo andare faccio io faccio io faccio
io famiglia che sbotta perfetto nel che
però il problema non è questo il
problema è che non ho capito perché sta
gente stavo scherzando è questo il più
grosso va bene è un po esagerato
suprema contro gli 8 ma questo ci fa il
culo
c'è già quasi uccisi ma come chi è che
dalle botte così cose a caso la pena ora
che sono bravi sono più bravo con la
spada che con le donne ma per questo e
si capiva danni inflitti mica vinto
karen pupa banane 6 livello 3 non riesce
a fare danni mio dio sa perché possono
che curare figo ha quindi puoi mancare
poi fare li sento odore di malvagità non
sono io che ho mollato zia aiuto per chi
prismi eterei equipaggio lì per vendere
i potenti più rinomata proviamo con
micaela micaela tesoro mio madonna che
il mio livello successivo ha quindi devo
far passare di livello giusto livello 4
senza odore di malvagità 9 delle pieghe
scoreggia nel che va beh c'è mago
merlino forse all'inizio c'era la storia
che non ho fatto in tempo a leggere
stavo facendo la intro orlando lei si
chiama orlando ma orlando bloom 6 torna
tornando sei tornato con le prove brand
africa per continuare vai così brand
alare liquida fonte del potere che può
scacciare il male i demoni cianni invaso
cece brenda non solo i demoni ci hanno
invaso anche le tue le tue tenere amiche
è fuffa
che diamine ma questo è sempre urlando
io combatto eccole orlando e lui io
combatto solo con orlando e legame che
assassinò perfetto vinto chiamare
cassano sono esageratamente potente cioè
non esiste la lenza per la guerra inter
server è così pronta all'azione unisciti
a noi va bene perché c'è questo qua che
mi ha linkato soggetto gettone
l'evocazione avanzata e per ripetere si
va a benzina non me ne frega che tu sei
fori e si è credi di essere forte ma io
lo sono di più ora che la gente ha
capito chi è che comanda una mercante
max che cosa vendi reggiseni da tezenis
numerosi oggetti disponibili in negozio
si sblocca a livello ventura aveva una
donna tanto c'è stamattina che
continuare andare in giro con il cesto
di vimini manco mi dovesse vendere la
frutta c'è il festival settimanale
veramente ottieni ottieni tutto forte ok
anche il giorno 2 ottimi tutto
lo sciacallo evoca un eroe leggendario
ce l'avevo questa evoca veloce ma
rischiamo tu hai il pene non va bene c'è
un cavallo cosa fammi salire in groppa
destriero cosa c'è la spada dell'eroe
l'elmo di ferro è solo l'elmo cia di
ferro posso aggiungere sta tizia quali
amici di facebook
devo andare scusatemi domanda c'è una
guerra in corso chi è veramente la
regina dei flagelli attila flagello di
dio fa vj ad evo devo picchiare forte
perché io volevo farlo in gruppo questo
va beh non fa niente sono mica quanto
levo adesso mi sono leggermente
potenziato era giusto per dire gli
spacco anche senza le supreme adesso è
vabbè mica sempre più grosso è lei che
se ci sono letizie belle devono aver
solo tutti più grossi sto gioco gigante
del gelo livello 6 quelli livello 100
quanto cazzo sono grossi scusate chiedo
è nessun eroe morto e ci mancherebbe
mi chiama su salendo di un miliardo di
livelli a caso è qui pato qui il patito
da gnocca è più taglia un colpo nobile
mio cugino si chiama nobile di cognome
che cazzo fai lanci mio cugino siete
entrambi piuttosto sky a tua sorella è
scarsa non è vero io sono un problema
è vero la germania e lui e livello 200
io sono scarsissimi porca eva scherzavo
scherzavo cintura della sociali pezzi
fottutissima ocse soro mio danni pezzi
che te la do camilla camilla sul cavallo
il mio cuore non è gelido
dipende se lo metti dentro al frigo pur
essendo il guardiano ti sei alleato con
gli orchi a lui è uno streaming pupa
banane ecco è entrata lei
fermi tutti che succede l'arbitro vuole
giustizia lo godiamo forte vai vai vai
vai carica la suprema picco viene
caricare prima la mia suprema perché poi
la uso contro qualcuno di potente tipo
adesso inizia a sentirsi un po la
difficoltà è mamma
avanti grazia minchia che male ci ha
fatto mai veloce perfetto ho vinto
vittoria ma i due stesso ho definito la
tua squadra minchia suo fortissimo
quindi possiamo essere solo in quattro
hanno anche di più proprio lo slow fra
lunedì ci sono le cavalcature va beh
posso averla cielo sono forte
cavalcatura riuscita pippa lunga io sono
pupa banane
sposiamoci non sono mai andata a cavallo
in vita mia tranne qua è colpa mia se la
reliquia andata perduta forse morire
l'unico modo per poter espiare le mie
colpe
la traduzione è fatta da dio però
accusato di tradimento pronta a morire
inutilmente questo non è il logo sting e
conosco ascolta pupa banane mazza
arancia de oro finazzi ce l'hai proprio
grossa
la lancia quando si ferma la musica in
un gioco mi cavo in mano è successo
spesso di essere morto vabbè ho parlato
è contento così in mezzo a sta gente
il giudice tutti con la suprema veloce
spaccate il culo forte cosa ma lanciato
state è morto nuovo eroe chi è la tizia
con una frusta pandora qualità
leggendario siete stati dei folli a
venire da me io sono il signore ma come
signore ma c'è le bocce il mietitore di
anime legge solo manga lei contro
pandora forte ok va vinto non ci sono
bocce che vengono erogati avanti cena
torre vedo un dirigibile che si avvicina
la torre comunque in tutto questo io
sono salito al 9 quindi se magari mi
fate fare un paio di livelli mica
livello 7 anche con micaela livello 8
livello 9 ma basta fatevi provare quanto
levano adesso va beh
ok va bene forse un po troppo ma così è
troppo facile miglior ali ricompense
quanto a roma ho lasciato indietro sori
non avevo capito
è stato tre stelle ovunque quindi
fantastico ciao camilla sono più forte
io guarda qua siamo all 1 di 11 poi c'è
la regina delle arpie credo di riuscire
ad arrivare da un ascensore abitato
mentre mentre guardi guardi intorno
questi hanno già vinto va bene
perfetto sono diventato fortissimo nuovo
eroe che si chiama giovanna e l'ha già
fatto madonna che botta in faccia però
stai molto calma pure tu e mica che
casino è morta poi son cagato addosso
leggermente regine alle api e sono qui
per eseguire il volere di sua maestà
vuoi vedere che cosa ne penso io di sono
messaggi ci siamo ragazzi battaglia
finale per oggi le ultime parole famose
ma un mimo schietto come niente troppo
tardi la reggina come partita ma vi
abbiamo preparato lo stesso un comitato
di benvenuto troppo a lungo abbiamo
atteso questa vendetta pupa banane
rubare la reliquia angelica un crimine
punibile con la morte ha evocato altra
gente però sono riuscito quasi a far
fuori tutti lo stesso vai su di lei
sulla reggina usa la suprema spacca lì
ma perché non muore o regalo detto è che
mi batte l'avevo detto io adoro far
fuori tutti gli altri prima scusate non
ho capito
[Musica]
abbiamo finito il capitolo 1 ragazzo
bloccata anche il forziere dragonero
ancora drago di ossa skoll drago di
ghiacci un finale che posso anche
cambiarmi l'abito fico però sono salito
all 11 in un video fatto 11 livelli va
beh posso già ancora vocale da evochiamo
ancora l'ultimo mission etico me ne vado
non ho parole è l'ultimo orlando se vi
interessa ve lo dico in server che nel
quale sono andato ai limp lean burn in
born così potete venire in quello dove
ho giocato anch'io e nel caso fatevi
vedere che siete più forti di me cosa
che dubito
nel caso aggiungetevi mi chiamo pupa
banane la vera che a suo dire che
possono chiudere qui il video spero che
vi sia piaciuto
gli ho detto anche il server quindi
libro nel caso lo sapete già tutto così
sono stata chiede nei commenti lascia
anche un figlio esistono ovviamente
alinghi league of angels io vi giuro che
se volevo prendere il telecomando ho
preso la spazzola un big laiche per
tutte le big miglaia camaiani facebook e
come remy adottata la notizia si
eserciti sette civili chiamano
proseguito bello ragazzi